well let's you know
talk about the elephant in the room
i'm not talking about my belly or my
dick
it looks slim thank you i'm talking
about
what happened to me and that people are
curious to see what happened to me and
uh i want to tell people
in the in the healthiest way i can
you know without going into extreme you
know details but um
essentially something happened um a
while back in my life
that um
just put me
that shocked me and it
kind of traumatized me and um
you know
it's okay babe i'm so sorry it's okay
baby so so rude so serious and the
largest so rude but you know what i'm
gonna let it go
these cardboard straws yeah
why don't i just queef into the [ __ ]
mic
let's do a [ __ ] heavy
filipino queef you know honestly i could
cliff on command if you want me to do
that right now can you yeah i can yeah
you know what it smells like durian
fruit
anyway uh
anyway anywho so can we go back i think
cleafing is so hot
yeah i do too yeah i've heard it like
you've never heard a girl queef have you
had sex in your life only on how well my
penis can't create that suction yeah but
i've always heard it on howard stern
like when they the girls come to the mic
and they actually just do it yeah
you know and also like exotic stinky
fruit in air form yeah yeah just hitting
my just in my face you know what i mean
so
it feels good as well when it rolls out
the [ __ ] it actually feels really good
okay can we can we okay gilbert only
does missionary style
hey hot take hot take um i'm talking
about my personal life oh yeah seriously
yeah hot take hello
so that you know i didn't know how to um
process anything and then
it was so funny sorry
we talked about queefing i know i know
and then i relapsed
yeah i talked about it first
and i just could i just i don't know i
didn't know i don't know what else to do
i um i started drinking and i went in
fast it just went fast and i apologize
george i mean
george
had to do a bunch of [ __ ] and i'm so
sorry
oh you all i'm sorry for everyone i used
to especially baby you had the worst i
know
i was just thinking about mexico about
what i had put them through but
but everyone in my life
went through hell
you know that
um
but when it happened is i started you
know drinking and
using it's just smoking pot but um
i was smoking cigarettes as well and
smoking so what i would do is you know i
just want to tell marijuana companies
um
just from my heart to you
can you please put in dosages on edible
packages because
you know i mean i don't know how many to
take right like a recommendation yeah
two
you know i mean 10 milligrams right
i would take i'm not kidding you
anywhere between you saw
a thousand
to 1500 milligrams i have a hot take
what i think that even if they were to
put every specific
word of information for you destruction
yeah it's like unisom unison tells you
do not take more than this many a day
and you were taking 20 a day 20 a day oh
that's exaggerated five but i'm just
saying it that's not what you're going
to abuse it regardless of what's on the
label
okay
is that the last hot take you're going
to do the first hot take was george
about gilbert's missionary oh sorry it
was
move on yeah with the story
so um
so i was taking a lahat and
every time i use something a phenomenon
happens and i went to
several different places in the last
month
and reputable places and um
i go into some sort of manic it's not
mania but i go into a place where
i just can't eat or sleep and no matter
how hard i try i can't do it you know i
mean i could drink like you just saw me
drinking you know i would drink alcohol
you know what i mean shots of you know
fire what's my favorite fireball
i drink a bunch of fireball beer smoked
beef we i just couldn't sleep i couldn't
eat you know and i was losing weight and
um
like i was literally getting one or two
hours a night you know i mean if that
for months
meanwhile going to like hawaii
new york
mexico
back to hawaii back to new york shooting
[ __ ] right
i don't remember really any of it you
know during shoots i don't use but but
toward the end i was i mean when i when
we did the jim gaffigan episode like you
obviously were very you didn't want
anyone to know that you had relapsed but
you were sweating so profusely so i know
you were withdrawing i want to apologize
to gaff again because i honestly i've
been dreaming to have that guy on my
podcast
and you know the reaction of it people
kind of liked i don't know i didn't read
any of the reactions but you know there
wasn't anything real negative but um
i just
was not my right side well you were
withdrawing so that's why you were it
was cold in this room it was terrible it
was the amount of sweat do you guys
remember that you were like what is
happening you also wore a gray shirt it
was yeah yeah so sweat ring around so
i'm going to tell you what happened so
what happened was i because i was
smoking pot and cigarette cigarettes i
started um coughing up blood
and i would like cough up they would be
like dark red blood in my mucus right
with other colors in it that i'd never
seen before
um
my chest started hurting real bad again
i couldn't breathe and um
and then bob saget died
and when they said that um
at the time they didn't know what
happened maybe it was a heart attack but
he died in sleep and what was disturbing
about it is that
you know i know that the day before
bob had died he talked to a good friend
of mine who i'm friends with
and bob was feeling great
he was so happy that he was back on the
road and he thought he
i think he said um
i'm finally finding my voice again i'm
so you know and then he died and i there
was no other
and i just went i started fixating on
death because you know i started
coughing up this blood right
and i i convinced myself that i had lung
cancer
and then
louis died
and you know louie i've opened for on
the road louie um he's just a friend of
mine i love him
and then i just kind of and without even
processing their death i just just
started really just focusing
on the days i had left on earth
and i thought it was
i could i was convinced
that i was going to die
i was [ __ ] convinced
and then um
i ended up in a
a trap which is
couldn't eat couldn't sleep
i'm dying
i'm using more than i've ever used in my
life
and then
it was like being in a prison
in my mind i was stuck
and you know
one night i just looked at kala and i
said
i need help i i i yeah i can't go on
i can't go on
so um
then the nightmare began you know i had
some really [ __ ] nightmares things
happen number one
we went to a place i'm not going to name
the place
which is highly recommended highly
recommend place unaware yelp
this is a good job
the story there's the joke that i needed
the way you described it yeah yeah
sounds like a restaurant in the valley
yeah yeah well here's it it was at the
haha cafe yeah on lancashire
what happened was all of these people
were like you're going to the best place
in america we've been there it changed
my life and like people that were like
close to us right yeah so what we didn't
know is the place had gotten bought out
in the last year
and is no longer a treatment center that
like is like oh here's a group of 20
people that we're gonna like do intense
work with it's now like a rehab mill
yeah where it's like just 150 to 250
people like just a little exaggeration i
exaggerated exaggerated that yeah so
let's go back to what the real number is
the real number is they said that there
was 15 people at one point you know that
they would
and the real number is about
80. still a lot right
but also the same staff
the amount of staff right
so you're not getting specific but
that's not even that it's like when i
was so
first of all it was funny because she's
like
first of all she got mad at me get this
she gets mad at me
for using
before going to rehab now
i only used
before going to react because i don't
want to be the only person in the
history of going to rehabs
showing up to rehab sober who [ __ ]
does that hey guys you don't be a loser
i've been sober for three months let's
tell them let's do this no i want to
show up naked with a stop sign wrapped
around my neck
on fire i mean that's
why that's how you show up to rehab
[Music]
grove collaborative for your
sake we need